se acercan las elecciones presidenciales
y esta será la votación por correo más
grande en la historia de eeuu debido a
la pandemia de kobe 19 la cámara de
representantes aprobó una legislación
con la que busca inyectar 25 mil
millones de dólares al servicio postal y
también bloquea una serie de cambios que
pueden dificultar los comicios presten
atención a lo que dice el presidente
porque todo está diseñado para suprimir
el voto hagan un plan para votar haganlo
para votar temprano para que tengamos un
resultado que sea claro lo más cerca
posible de la noche de elección el
proyecto de ley se enmarca en la
polémica que generó el director del
servicio postal cuando decidió hacer
cambios drásticos como retirar buzones
de recolección y recortar horas extras
con el objetivo de reducir costos aunque
luego dijo que esas medidas no entrarían
en vigencia hasta después de las
elecciones el presidente de donald trump
había instado a rechazar la legislación
presentada por los demócratas
argumentando sin pruebas que este tipo
de votación favorece el fraude
todo esto es una broma de los demócratas
para dar 25 mil millones de dólares
innecesarios para fines políticos sin
hablar de la estafa en el voto por
correo que están tratando de llevar a
cabo en violación de todo lo que nuestro
país representa el proyecto también
tendrá que llegar al senado de mayoría
republicana pero el líder de la cámara
alta- dijo que no la aprobarán si pasa
esta sería una intervención sin
precedentes en la oficina de correos
cuyos fondos provienen del negocio de la
correspondencia y otros servicios y no
del dinero de los impuestos